welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show and today I'm joined by Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being Greg
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me on how you doing today doing well how
are you I am doing great we got a lot of
good stuff to cover in the show today uh
before we get into that if you like the
show and you'd like to support it there
are many ways you can do that you can
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
the show you can join our email
newsletter by going to
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter we
send out a research update every single
Wednesday uh really nice information
straight to your inbox uh you could
check out our online coaching program we
have coaches who do one-on-one virtual
coaching you can learn more about uh you
know that service and who our coaches
are by going to strongerbyscience.com
coaching you can use our discount code
to get a discount on your supplements
over at bulksupplements.com just use the
code SBS pod it'll get you a five
percent discount of course you could
subscribe to the mass research review uh
many of you did during our big black
Friday and Cyber Monday sale thank you
so much for the new people who have
joined us
um and thanks to the old people who have
been with us for all this time uh mass
is now I think mass is entering what
like the seventh year I believe so yeah
yeah entering uh volume seven here so
some folks have been with us for a
really really long time and we sincerely
appreciate that another thing you could
do is check out macro factor it's the
diet app that we co-designed
co-developed with a really talented team
of folks and there is a free trial so
you can check it out take it for a spin
and see if you like it
um all right so let's do some business
here regarding the podcast schedule over
the next few weeks
um
obviously last week for the first time
ever we did a re-airing of a prior
episode and that was for a very good
reason like I mentioned in the
introduction last week that was
basically kick-starting a string of
shows that are going to lead us into the
new year obviously New Year is a really
big time for Fitness people start
putting together some goals and some
plans for the upcoming year and so we
wanted to tailor our content in December
and January to make sure that we were
kind of focusing on topics that were
related to that so we could be hopefully
uh as helpful as we possibly can so last
episode was a re-aired episode of a
really long discussion really detailed
discussion about goal setting uh today
in this episode we are going to build
upon that we're going to do a very brief
review of goal setting and then we're
going to talk about motivation and
behavior change and I'm going to explain
how all those Concepts kind of work
together goal setting motivation and
behavior change
um and then in the future
we've got a number of shows that are
already planned out we're going to be
talking about how to actually structure
a weight loss diet how to uh incorporate
things like mindful eating how to
incorporate cardio for weight loss and
what kind of effects you can actually
expect from doing that and we're also
going to talk a little bit about the
importance of sleep so we've got a whole
line of shows that are planned out and
ready to go and today like I said it's
going to be all about motivation and
behavior change but
before we get into that I did want to
talk briefly about the most recent
Stronger by science article
um so one of the big misconceptions in
the world of evidence-based Fitness is
that meta-analyzes basically Trump
everything all the time so you'll you'll
see people engaging in chatter uh
somewhere between a discussion and an
argument on the internet about some
topic someone will say yeah but look at
this study where where X Y and Z happen
and someone will say
get your pathetic randomized controlled
trial out of my face because I have a
fresh PubMed link to a meta analysis
which is at the top of the hierarchy of
evidence and this discussion is
officially closed
um and in my article I push back against
that a little bit I I wouldn't say I
push back entirely
um conceptually I do think that there's
a reason that systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes have a well-earned spot at
the top of the hierarchy of evidence but
the hierarchy of evidence there's an
underlying assumption there which is
that all these different forms of
evidence
have been gathered or conducted
effectively right so the the hierarchy
of evidence kind of goes out the window
if you're comparing two forms of
evidence uh and one is just riddled with
errors and the other was done quite
proficiently and effectively so
I wrote an article which was originally
for the mass research review which is
also posted on strongerbyscience.com and
the title is scrolling up
um meta-analyzes are the gold standard
for evidence but what's the value of
gold these days uh and so the reason I
called it that is because I was
reviewing a paper by Kadlec and
colleagues uh their paper was called
with great power comes great
responsibility common errors and
meta-analyzes and meta regressions in
strength and conditioning research so
the general idea was you know yeah we've
got this hierarchy of evidence and
that's good and I certainly don't uh
have major issues with the the general
uh structure of the hierarchy of
evidence but like I said the the
underlying assumption there is that
these meta-analyzes are at the top of
the hierarchy uh and we assume that
they've been done very proficiently and
are not they don't contain errors and
the main point of this really really
good paper by Kadlec and colleagues
is that we really can't rest on that
assumption in our field currently that
when you come across a meta-analysis
that it will be done very proficiently
and it will be free of statistical
errors
um so in my article I talked a little
bit about I started by talking about the
origin of meta-analyzes
um had you ever heard that story before
uh I think you were the one who told it
to me okay that makes sense I I have
known you for a while
um we talk about this [ __ ] but so um I
always find it really interesting
because meta-analyzes like I said
they've kind of gotten this reputation
in our little bubble in evidence-based
Fitness of being
indisputable Untouchable Beyond reproach
and I think it's helpful historically to
look back at where a meta-analyzes
originated where they came from
um and also I thought it was an
interesting look back at discourse in
science I think we often have
um I think a lot of folks make the
assumption that back in the day there
were all these very great thinkers who
were very calm and academic in terms of
how they approach questions always very
even keeled even temperament and they
wouldn't get in the social media dust
ups that we that we indulge these days
um
I don't know why we make that assumption
because they were humans and we are too
and man uh the the first thing that you
would call a contemporary attempt at
meta-analysis really was just a giant
beef between almroth Wright and Carl
Pearson
um and the beef was about the typhoid
vaccine the vaccine for typhoid fever
um it was just tearing through the
British Military and uh almroth Wright
said hey I've got a vaccine for that
it's pretty cool I really like it you
should too
um and it started kind of trickling out
and the thing about Elm Roth right is
that he hated statistics
um not just like oh I don't like doing
it he thought statistics and bear in
mind we're talking about turn of the
century like early early 1900s he
thought it was a waste of time he
basically I'm putting words in his mouth
but it was kind of like it's just kind
of an annoying fad that that will go
away eventually and even if it doesn't I
just don't have a use for statistics for
inferential statistics yeah uh now Carl
Pearson you'll probably recognize his
name from the Pearson correlation
coefficient
um
so he thought statistics were cool which
is why he pioneered a great a great
number of uh you know theoretical
Concepts and calculations and procedures
uh little tip don't read literally any
biographical information about Carl
Pearson no no no no or Ronald Fisher uh
just if someone was a famous
statistician
more than like 20 years ago just just
leave it alone you don't need to don't
even look up the name of the department
they chaired it was it wasn't the
statistics department or the mathematics
Department yeah so I'll just leave it at
that if you know they say don't meet
your Heroes don't read about your Heroes
if they're statisticians yes just leave
it alone and say hey math works and
that's good but anyway so Wright and
Pearson we're having this big dust up
back and forth calling each other names
you know saying the other one was full
of [ __ ] it was a very entertaining
exchange that was that was taking place
publicly and people were trying to
intervene and be like hey guys the
let's relax we're talking about health
care here but nonetheless people
eventually said Hey You Know Carl
Pearson please do something with all of
this data about the typhoid vaccine and
like I said right uh was was doing a lot
of this work of actually administering
the vaccine uh but he hated statistics
so he did not take records in a way that
would be suitable for a thorough robust
statistical analysis it was it was
really chaotic and disorganized so
Pearson tries to throw it together
Stitch it up and say you know I don't
have computers I also don't have very
good data but anyway here's a
meta-analysis that I just came up with
yeah um
the reason I bring that up is because I
think if you were to dichotomize the
outcome was Pearson's analysis correct
or incorrect
of course it's more complicated than
that but I guess I would go with
incorrect honestly because he was like
ah we probably shouldn't rush to to you
know really escalate the use of this
vaccine the vaccine was effective it was
quite effective it ended up saving a lot
of people's lives
um and so I like to bring that up
because it gets down to the the general
con aside from being interesting and
watching people get in like a Facebook
argument a hundred years ago aside from
that
um I think it's interesting to to kind
of reinforce the point that a
meta-analysis is only as good as the
actual calculations being done and the
underlying data right so if you
meta-analyze crappy data you're not
going to get a good result or if you
have great data and you use a really
heavy-handed or erroneous approach to
calculations you're also not going to
get great uh great information from it
and you know Pearson he did what he
could but like I said computers didn't
exist so doing a meta-analysis was quite
an undertaking in 1905 or it was
somewhere around there that he was doing
this
so that's where we started with
meta-analyzes it's not like they start
from this like oh we had all these
problems couldn't solve them somebody
came through and answered all these
questions perfectly
um but let's switch to the modern day
here
um what what Kadlec and colleagues did
in this study was they looked at the 20
most cited meta-analyzes in the field of
strength and conditioning and they
basically screened them for common
statistical errors now I would have to
assume I'm speculating here that
they basically did this project because
they read enough metas in this field and
said
I kind of know what I'm looking for you
know like I I think that these
hypothesize light bulb went out
I think that these hypotheses uh were
this will be a cool or are we just gonna
keep rolling with mood lighting
uh yeah I say I think so sure why not
people are gonna love this keep it loose
yeah we just had a light bulb go out if
you're listening on uh Audio Only
platforms so the mood has changed very
much and now it's it's really dark and
shadowy and and uh quite mysterious I
would say
um but anyway so they look at the 20
most cited meta-analyzes and strength
and conditioning and like I said I
speculate that they kind of knew what
they were looking for already yeah it's
it's hard to read too many metas in our
field without
recognizing that there are a handful of
of pretty pervasive problems that that
crop up a lot exactly yeah so
one of the things that I like to
highlight when talking about this
particular study is they went for the 20
most cited meta-analyzes so I would
argue personally that they kind of
stacked the deck against themselves in
terms like if they were just trying to
cherry pick and say oh my God look at
this High number of Errors you probably
wouldn't go for the most cited because
uh you know citation metrics that's a
conversation of its own you know it's
not a reliable indicator of quality but
uh it's not like they were looking for
the crappiest you know most ignored
meta-analysis that somehow snuck through
the crappiest journal in the field right
they weren't like scraping the bottom of
the barrel they just said let's go to
the ones that everybody's citing and
using for their arguments you know so I
I thought about this a little bit more
and I'm I'm actually not sure I agree
with that anymore
um I I think that that is a very
reasonable initial assessment meant to
make but I think I I think you and I are
both of the perspective that the average
quality of meta-analysis in our field is
trending upwards like it's yeah you know
like you you still you still find some
some stuff that probably shouldn't slip
through through review but like I mean
it's it's even noticeably better now
than it was
two or three years ago yeah and when you
look at a lot of the years on these on
these metas
um like just going down the list
starting with the most cited and working
down 2009 2012 2004 2010 2009 2014 2016
2012. uh like there there are a couple
in here from 2018 but nothing thereafter
yeah
um so I I think that I think that these
are probably better than the average
meta-analysis was during the same time
period but I I do think the average
meta-analysis getting published today is
probably of a similar quality or
slightly better I would say it's
probably
similar so so like I think the way that
I summarized it in the article or the
way I framed it is
what I see in meta-analyzes today is
first of all they're more numerous in
quantity
I see a
a widening of the gap between the good
ones and the bad ones yeah uh so I I
think this was from a uh the majority of
these studies are from a time period
where the good ones weren't as good
um so yeah I don't think like if you
were going to stack the deck fully and
say like I'm gonna make it really hard
to find an error then you'd probably say
okay well what we're going to do is go
at the
you know 25 most recent ones published
in a high quality Journal that only
publishes systematic reviews like you
would go to like sports medicine which
almost exclusively publishes reviews
um it kind of has the best reputation I
would say of journals in our field when
it comes to systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes specifically like so I I
there would be a way for them to stack
the deck more aggressively against
themselves for sure because like like
you said I mean they're getting better
over time especially the the higher
quality ones are getting much more
sophisticated
um but but there's still a lot of those
just bottom of the barrel ones that are
sneaking through and you're like what
happened here right yeah no I I agree
with that yeah so I I think we're
definitely on the same page there where
I they certainly weren't making it easy
for themselves by going for the 20 most
cited I think it's probably pretty
representative all things considered
when you factor in the fact that things
are getting better over time but there
are also so just a lot of bad metas that
are coming out even today
so when it comes to the errors that they
were screening for
um one was ignoring outliers which is
pretty self-explanatory like
um ideally when you're doing a
meta-analysis or reading it you know the
whole purpose is to
derive really useful insights from the
data and it is kind of uh frustrating
when you look at a meta-analysis and
there's like one or two or three studies
that are just on a different planet in
terms of effect size and you're just
like are you gonna mention that like
that seems important if we're
summarizing this literature it would be
important to know why those are out
there and how much they're impacting the
analysis uh number two miscalculated
effect sizes that arise from using
standard errors instead of standard
deviations
um pretty self-explanatory happens way
too much usually you can identify it by
just glancing at the forest plot uh and
reviewers don't yeah so there's that
well and that dovetails with number one
because if you're if you're screening
for outliers most of the time those
miscalculated effect sizes using
standard errors will also be outliers
yeah yeah those are usually the same
thing it's usually that the outliers are
miscalculated effect sizes uh not always
but but often should we give just like a
little bit more background for people
who who don't have any statistics
background for like why the standard
error standard deviation thing is
specifically a problem sure go for it
sure so
um
typically uh so if if you've heard of of
a bell curve for instance or just like a
a standard or like a normal distribution
of something
um generally that's going to be
described with a with a mean and a
standard deviation
um and so like something within Plus or
one or plus or minus one standard
deviation from the mean that's about
two-thirds of your data plus or minus
two standard deviations that's about 95
percent of your data plus or minus three
standard deviations that's like
99.8 99.9 of your data it's it's most of
it
um and yeah not not too much data more
than three standard deviations from the
mean so it's it tells you basically how
spread out your data is
um but then for the purposes of like
Computing a p-value or a t statistic or
or whatever
um like for kind of the next step of
your analysis us where you're trying to
determine like hey how how different are
these means you want to take the sample
size into account and so essentially
like if you if if you uh you know study
one group of people take their bench
press one rep max and it's a hundred
kilograms plus or minus 10 kilos so that
plus or minus standard deviation
um and that's based on eight total
subjects versus you get the exact same
distribution 100 plus or minus 10 kilos
uh with its with a sample of a thousand
subjects you can be a lot more confident
in in that distribution of results and
of your mean results which is which are
ultimately trying to estimate uh with
the sample of a thousand then the sample
of eight and so if you're comparing like
hey we we took this other sample of
people who bench press
110 plus or minus 10 kilos uh are these
two sample means different
um essentially you want to treat the
sample of a thousand as if there's way
way more Precision in that estimate
because there is you you sampled a lot
more people
um and so what you do to calculate a
standard error is just divide the
standard deviation by the square root of
the N of the of the like group size
you're dealing with
um and the N is the sample size just to
be super clear yeah yeah and so
essentially like you know if you have
um yeah if it's a hundred plus or minus
10 and there's like nine people per
group you would divide that ten by three
the square root of nine and so your
standard error would be like 3.333
repeating uh if it's a hundred plus or
minus 10 and you have a hundred subjects
in the group you divide by the square
root of 10 so your standard error would
just be one essentially just again
denoting that your estimate your
estimate of the mean is a lot more
precise and reliable if you're dealing
with a larger sample size to start with
and so where this becomes a problem is
standard errors are just mathematically
always smaller than standard deviations
uh and that's especially problematic if
you have like a huge group so you know
shrinking that plus or minus 10 down to
plus or minus 1 with the standard error
if you have that sample size of a
hundred but regardless like no matter
how big your group is even with just
nine subjects you know you're you're
shrinking it down to one-third of of
what the size was and so if you're
calculating an effect size in the
Cohen's D family generally what you're
calculating is a difference between
groups divided by a standard deviation
and so if you just mess up and plug a
standard error in there as well or if
you plug a standard error in instead of
a standard deviation you're making the
denominator of that of that fraction
that you're creating much much smaller
and so that has the effect of massively
inflating the effect size so an effect
size that maybe should have been you
know a d of 0.4 like a relatively small
effect size if you mess up and use the
standard error instead now instead of
0.4 it might be like 1.5 because you
just you know you just made that little
slip up
um so yeah generally if you make that
mistake and plug a standard error into
an effect size formula instead of a
standard deviation it will have the
effect of massively inflating the effect
size and like I said generally those
things will be outliers as well like it
it should jump off the page at you but
not always so if if something would
otherwise have a trivial effect like a a
d or a g value of like 0.1.15 and you
accidentally plug in a standard error
you know now you might still wind up
with an erroneously calculated effect
size that looks reasonable in magnitude
like yeah maybe 0.4.5 whatever doesn't
really jump off the page at you but it's
still you know inflated two three four
five fold bigger than than it should
have been yeah and I uh
my number if I'm just like reading
through a meta for the first time if
you're giving me a Cohen's D or a Hedges
G and you're saying yeah it was about a
three three and a half
I'm looking at the full text like I'm
gonna go in and be like are you sure
yeah uh and you know I I will say like
there are some
um original papers like not to put
that's what 100 of the blame on The Meta
now on the meta-analysts here there are
some original papers where clearly the
authors have uh
said here's a standard deviation and
it's actually a standard error yeah I
have absolutely seen that before now 100
ideally a meta-analyst would be looking
at it very closely and and there would
there should be in a well-reported study
enough contextual factors where you
would be able to sort that out
um but but you know sometimes it happens
and sometimes it goes from a super super
super tiny effect size to a very small
effect size like you mentioned so this
stuff can get a little a little messy a
little a little technical but um anyway
yeah so it's it can be a problem and
like I said if I ever see an effect size
above three and a forest plot my first
thought is are we sure that's a standard
deviation that got put in here yeah uh
so the third one is ignoring within
study correlation and that might sound
uh very jargony and Technical but it's
actually it's typically quite simple
it's you know correlated observations
are are basically when you're getting
multiple effect sizes in a meta-analysis
that are coming from the same sample of
individuals
um and you can extend that out with some
of the more nuanced modeling techniques
into even multiple samples from the same
study
um
ought to be correlated to some extent uh
just because of you know all the other
factors of study design that are similar
among those samples but um getting it
down to you know very very basic
language here sometimes you'll see a
study where they're like yeah we are
measuring strength outcomes and we got
bench press and leg press and you know
back squat and deadlift so sometimes in
a meta-analysis you'll see that the
analysts
opted to use four different data points
from the same group and treat that as if
it was just four totally different
groups of people in terms of how the
math mathematically how the data were
crunched and so of course that that runs
into a number of statistical issues
where some individuals are having really
undue influence on on the analysis and
it's just generally statistically
problematic to be double counting or
triple counting or quadruple counting
individuals within the analysis uh
number four is focusing on within group
rather than between group results uh a
great example of this that came up I
reviewed a meta-analysis on vitamin D
and uh you know normally with an effect
size you're looking at what was the
effect of the vitamin D group
compared to the effect observed in the
placebo group
um that that's really how you want to
frame that effect size it's not just
what was the effect in the vitamin D
group you want to say what was the
effect in the vitamin D group above and
beyond the effect of the placebo within
this study
um but I reviewed a meta-analysis in
Mass a couple years back with vitamin D
where in terms of calculating effect
sizes they just pretended the placebo
groups didn't exist you know and so
ultimately that's just uh
losing a great deal of pertinent
information and basically sacrificing uh
one of the key elements of what makes
the randomized controlled trial so
valuable right if you're if you're doing
that you're effectively getting rid of
the the major advantages of doing a
randomized controlled trial in the first
place yeah
um and then finally uh failing to
account for within study variance
basically uh when you're doing an
analysis you would like for it to be
weighted in a meta-analysis
um I I had someone ask me a question the
other day of like kind of Niche examples
of instances where perhaps you might not
want to do waiting within meta-analysis
but broadly speaking you you'd prefer to
have a weighted analysis for your
meta-analyzes and what that means is
um there's different ways that you can
wait a minute a meta-analysis inverse
variance weighting is the most common in
our field but generally speaking what
that means is the bigger studies get a
little bit more a little bit more pull
in the analysis uh they kind of anchor
the analysis more
um they tend to have more precise effect
estimates so basically you've got to
study with you know 30 000 people over
here in a study with 30 people over here
which effect size do you have more
confidence in uh probably the one with
30 000 people right yeah you know so you
want to make sure that your analysis
reflects the fact that when you have
these tiny groups of people your effect
effect estimates tend to be a little bit
more there's more volatility they kind
of bounce around a little bit due to
sampling error with much bigger studies
you have a little bit less of that you
know volatility you kind of start to
triangulate more into the kind of
quote-unquote true population level
effect size estimate uh so those are the
five main uh error that they were
looking for in this paper
if you want more detail obviously you
know you can get into really
nitty-gritty explanations of all those
but just looking at the prevalence
numbers here what percent of these 20
metas ignored outliers and just you know
didn't account for them didn't adjust
for them didn't comment on them
basically
um 25 which is pretty high number what
percentage miscalculated effect sizes
because they use standard errors instead
of deviations uh 45 very high number uh
what percent ignored within study
correlations 45 again uh which how many
of them focused on within group rather
than between group outcomes that was 45
again that was honestly shocking to me
yeah yeah that was surprising the the
first three I was like okay yeah like
that that makes sense I've read a lot of
metas I see those those things all the
time uh but yeah the the within study
versus between or the within group
versus between group effects I I did not
expect that to be an issue in in 45
percent of them yeah like I I agree that
one snuck up on me I was also surprised
by number five failing to account for
within study variants uh that ended up
being 40 uh which was higher than I
would have thought
um so again with these prevalence
numbers Greg you brought up a really
good point that
you know to what extent do they reflect
the current state of the literature like
a brand new meta-analysis that comes out
it's hard to say because the beta the
the better metas in our field are
getting better at a very rapid rate but
there is such a high number of metas
that are coming out now that just the
sheer volume of crappy metas is getting
higher
um so the the question of how does that
affect the kind of mean or median
quality I'm not entirely certain about
that at this point but
um in lieu of better prevalence numbers
this is kind of you know these are what
we have to work with and I I do think
that they are number one uh fairly
representative of the current state of
metas uh but number two and more
importantly
these numbers are too damn High Greg
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
have 45 percent of your metas out there
uh so the number that that really made
the headlines here
um
where's the number I I think the the
overall number was 85 I I believe so
yeah yeah so I'm pretty certain that you
know we talked about the prevalence of
individual errors but yeah the
researchers in this paper found that 85
of these top 20 metas contain at least
one statistical error
um so I'm not gonna you know go through
the entirety of the article here but if
you happen to check it out it's uh
Stronger by science.com
meta-analyzes it'll be linked in the
show notes you can really dig into the
details what I did in the article is I
walked through when I when I first read
this article I said I believe that we
have covered all of this in Mass before
um now we've never I mean I'm not like
saying oh we we you know totally had
this we scooped them yeah um because we
never put the effort or
effort into into actually doing a formal
analysis like I think the researchers
should be absolutely commended they did
a terrific job they did a much better
job than than I or we would have done
um so I I couldn't be uh happier that
they spearheaded this project but as I
was going through it I was like I know
that we've pointed out most if not all
of these just because we had to when we
were reviewing that as previously in
Mass it was like I can't review this
without highlighting this error and why
it matters
um and so I was very tickled as I went
back through our archive to find
for every one of these errors I was able
to find a mass article where we flagged
it identified it and explained you know
why it was problematic so yeah as I was
reading this uh this paper
um by Cadillac and colleagues the whole
time I was just kind of nodding saying
like yep yeah I know that and and it was
one of those times where the science is
really just reflective of your
experience where you're like yeah this
this all definitely definitely checks
out yeah so in the article there's two
things I wanted to do uh I wanted to be
helpful not snarky uh which is a new
thing for me but I so I wasn't just
trying to like pile on like
some of these errors are very forgivable
some of them are very understandable
um in fact I there are even some
instances where
like there there are some papers that
include meta regressions or certain
analyzes that technically violate one or
two of these rules but I still think are
very informative very insightful and
actually very intuitive ways to kind of
get at the data broadly speaking so I I
don't want people to think that if a
paper maybe has like one thing here for
one of its like six analyzes that it's
like oh these authors are idiots throw
out the whole paper don't even look at
it certainly don't get any insights from
it that's really not the case like just
with any other statistical thing like
when I first started learning about
statistics I just wanted to like
memorize a rule book I was like give me
the rules I'll learn them and then I'll
play by the rules but the more you get
into it you start getting into Concepts
where there are like opinions and
perspectives and degrees of wrongness
and where you draw the line between two
wrong and not wrong enough like it it
there's a lot of
um room for argument and debate with
with some of these things and there are
instances where you'd say like you know
does this figure
um you know fail to account for within
study variants yes is it still very very
informative for answering the research
question also yes you know you do run
into that stuff I remember one time and
I mean even with that example like the
the extent to which it matters just
depends on the the group of studies
you're dealing with like if it's
something where you know there's one or
two studies with like 500 subjects per
group and then 20 with you know 10 15
subjects per group then it's like yeah
that that should probably be weighted
but if if it's a if it's a meta where
you know there's eight studies going
into it and all of the studies have
between 12 and 20 subjects per group
uh should you wait it sure if you don't
wait it are you going to wind up with a
dramatically different effect estimate
nah not really so yeah yeah even even
something that that is like technically
something you should do the the extent
to which it actually matters like the
the extent to which it'll actually
affect your your effect estimates and
therefore the conclusions you draw
um yeah it it varies meta to meta yeah
and and some of these errors like I'll
look at a paper and I'll know exactly
why they did it because I'll be like I
see what you're getting at with this
analysis and I don't know what software
I would use to actually answer that
question and check all these boxes like
you you it exists I mean if nothing else
you could do it yourself you know you
could get in a really flexible program
like R and just do the math if you're
good enough to do that I'm not but yeah
there's there's some questions where
you'll see what people are trying to do
like so a good example is like you'll
see break point analyzes are like
non-linear approach which is to to
regression where they fail to weight the
studies because they're just using kind
of a standard regression approach rather
than a meta regression approach just
based on what softwares have to offer
um just like out of the box software so
all of that is to say uh the point here
is not to be hyper critical or snarky
it's just to kind of highlight some of
these common errors so that as you're
reading through papers you can identify
them and uh and contextualize the
findings and keep these things in mind I
was going to say one of the things about
I was talking about like uh
differences of opinion and perspective
and statistics I remember one time
I was really lucky I took a class with a
really good statistician who had he was
probably pushing 80 years old he had
seen everything he had been in the field
forever and was really really well
respected for sure and I remember one
time
um he said something in a lecture and I
was like that that strikes me as being
I'm not saying wrong but contradictory
to everything I've ever heard on the
topic and so then I like spent like an
entire evening just Googling and
Googling and Googling getting into like
message boards that only people with a
PhD in statistics are even like aware of
and I'm digging into the details and I
eventually find a reference supporting
this statement and the reference it
leads me to a footnote uh and it said
this is true because
so and so said it and it was my
professor and like so basically like
people in the like tiniest most nuanced
statistical circles were actually like
yeah like Bill made a really really good
argument for this and it's definitely
you know a really solid perspective but
like in terms of like is it right or
wrong it really just depends on who
feels that they've been convinced of it
you know so all that is to say
statistics when you start getting into
some of these topics it's not totally
black and white sometimes there are some
gray areas and
um the the total impact or the relative
impact of an error like you said is very
context dependent so number one just
trying to flag some of these errors uh
so that readers are aware of them and
can keep them in mind
number two in the article I provide a
checklist uh for reading a meta-analysis
it's a 10-point checklist and it's
basically if you open up a brand new
meta and you say okay what am I looking
for here it's the 10 items that I think
people really should have in mind
whenever they read a meta-analysis so
I'm not going to bore people by reading
through these 10 points one by one uh
not great radio in my opinion but
they're in the article and I definitely
recommend checking it out the overall
tone of the article
um you know it's important to clarify
the point I'm making on the point I'm
not making so I'm definitely not saying
like oh metas are so bad you should just
disregard them netas are a very very
powerful tool they deserve to be at the
top of the hierarchy of evidence
um but we still ought to do them
as best we can you know we should as a
field be very compelled to get better
and better and better with our metas
um so Meadows are still great but we
should read them critically and
skeptically just like we read any other
research we should not say well it's a
meta so damn I guess I'm wrong right I
mean maybe you are but a meta you know
we still have to really rigorously uh
interpret them look for some of these
key errors and contextualize their
findings accordingly
um
all right I think that's all I had to
say on that uh on that oh yeah I did
want to mention uh shout out to Charlie
Poole uh I gave him an acknowledgment in
the article I was so lucky man uh
Charlie Poole taught a course at my
University on meta-analyzes
and he's he's in the um the stats and
methods group of the Cochrane
collaboration if you have ever heard of
like a Cochrane review they're basically
like the governing authoritative body on
I would say systematic review
methodology and also just the general
concept of evidence-based practice
um
and
if I if unless I'm mistaken I believe
it's named after Archie Cochran who kind
of came up with evidence-based practice
as a thing uh I could be wrong on that
so I'm sure people will fact check me
and you know dunk on me in the
appropriate channels but anyway uh so
Charlie Poole is I mean he's forgotten
more about meta-analyzes than I'll ever
know
um and so yeah I just uh want to give
him a shout out because without taking
his course I would know zero of the
things that I wrote about in this
article so major props to Charlie and
like I said if you're interested in the
article make sure you give it a read it
is free it's on our website and it is
linked in the show notes the the one
thing I would add is
um like so when when I when I posted
this on Instagram it did the the post
itself did really well and and there
were a lot of comments on the post and
there was a particular flavor of like
reactionary con or like reactionary
comment to to the Post into this content
in general that I think is
like I understand how people got there
but I also think it's a reasonably
indefensible perspective which is you
know just people being like well if if
85 percent of these metas have errors uh
yeah that mean that means meta-analyzes
are fake and that uh anyone who's like
trying to cite meta-analyzes to to
support a particular point they have no
idea what they're talking about like
this shit's all all just fake news
um
but like the the thing is like this the
the study itself that you were writing
about in in your article about it like
one of one of the key points is that
all of these errors are reasonably easy
to spot yeah
um like if you either read the the
article by by Catholic and colleagues or
uh Eric's article about their article
um
you you should you should be able to
relatively quickly and easily gain the
tools to spot these errors
um and then like just just account for
them yourself basically which which
doesn't necessarily have to include like
re-extracting all of the data and like
re-running a meta-analysis for yourself
but you know for instance like it's not
it's not hard to spot an outlier like
it's not hard to spot uh studies where
they they use standard errors instead of
standard deviations to calculate effect
sizes like it does require more legwork
on your part pulling up some of those
individual studies with some effect
sizes that might seem suspect
um it's an it's not hard to like just
note whether they waited the studies or
not
um you know they'll either say hey we
did inverse variance waiting and then on
on the right column of the uh of the
forest plot they do you can see like
different weights for each one
um
or or they just don't and you know if
you just you know if there's eight
effect estimates in a forest plot if you
just plug them into a calculator and
divide by eight and you get the exact
mean effect reported and like ah yeah
they probably didn't wait it
um
but yeah like this
this is all like pretty simple basic
stuff to spot for yourself so yeah like
uh and like we mentioned before the the
average quality of of metas at least
that are getting published in high
quality journals is is trending up over
time so like this is at least in part a
snapshot of the state of met of
meta-analyzes in our field five ten
years ago
um so yeah like
basic basically what we're trying to say
is don't uh don't throw the baby out
with the bath water entirely like a well
done meta-analysis is still incredibly
valuable and a lot of these common
errors in meta-analyzes you
uh you you shouldn't feel disempowered
like oh if if they made a mistake
there's no way I could ever spot this
and so I shouldn't look at metas at all
because they might lead me to erroneous
conclusions etc etc like that that is
not what you should take from this
um it's just like there is a skill set
required for critically reading and
evaluating any type of research and
there is a specialized sub skill set
within that General skill set of being
able to critically read understand and
analyze meta-analyzes and and spot some
of these errors that pop up from time to
time but those those aren't tremendously
difficult skills to pick up like you you
should be able to spot these errors for
yourself and
um you know be able to account for that
so you can still read meta-analyzes and
and derive uh you know correct and
beneficial conclusions from them yeah I
mean along those lines I'm sure people
will hear this or see it and say well
man if all these you know professors
that are reviewing these papers who have
been taught how to do this if they're
not catching these errors what chance do
I have you know and one of the things I
mentioned in the article which is uh
kind of a poorly kept secret is like
I've been I I've spent a lot of my time
hanging around you know professors grad
students in the field
I don't know of a department that
actually has a class in their Department
about
the statistics of meta-analyzes I I've
never heard of such a thing the only
reason I was able to access that course
was because it was way across campus in
a totally different department I sought
it out myself and people thought I was
kind of a dumbass for doing it honestly
uh it turned out to be like one of the
best courses I took in in all my my
schooling but you know the reality is
with reviewing these metas
a lot of the folks that are reviewing
them uh have never done a meta-analysis
or you know run you know crunch the
numbers for it and have never taken a
course that demonstrates how to do that
and they're going into this with
um
I I would argue kind of insufficient
information to review a metacritically
personally
um so yeah if you're kind of assuming
like man this has gotten through people
who are really well trained in this
particular thing that's actually usually
not the case uh which is which is a
whole separate problem entirely
um but but yeah I mean this does not
mean that metas aren't helpful and
useful but it means hey they're a piece
of research and we have to read research
critically you know
laughs
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
alright moving on I'm going to talk a
little bit here about motivation and
behavior change so
last uh January January 3rd 2000 well I
guess
is that last January I guess it's
technically this January yeah of 2022
about a year ago I'll say that I
published an article called an
evidence-based approach to goal setting
and behavior change you can find it
stronger by science.com goal setting and
uh that was the the kind of topic of
last week's episode the re-aired episode
and the the focal point basically is
goal setting
uh and a couple of little tips and
strategies for turning goals into action
but the article in hindsight definitely
lacked two important things
um
not necessarily a weakness of the
article but you can't write one article
about all things right you gotta you
gotta cut it at some point
that article lacked a comprehensive
framework for understanding and
promoting motivation and it also lacked
a comprehensive framework for
understanding and promoting sustainable
Behavior change and so that is what this
segment's all about I want to pick up
where goal setting uh left off and kind
of build on it from there
so before we talk about specific
theories or strategies we need to
probably Define motivation and there's
three definitions that I think are
sometimes I like to use multiple
definitions so you get kind of a Vibe a
more well-rounded kind of look at what a
word means rather than just saying we
have to pick one specific definition and
ignore all the others so three
definitions I'll put out there one is
for motivation
psychological energy directed at a
particular goal number two the
energizing of behavior in pursuit of a
goal and number three the process
whereby goal directed activities are
initiated and sustained in expectancy
value Theory motivation is a function of
the expectation of success and perceived
value so that gives us a nice
well-rounded idea of when we say
motivation what exactly are we talking
about but it also one of the things
you'll note there is that motivation
pertains to a goal right the first two
uh first two definitions goal was the
last word we're talking about motivation
as it pertains to some goal so before we
talk about cultivate cultivating
motivation we need to figure out what
our goals are because the motivation is
specifically in reference to them so
I don't want to rehash everything from
last week's episode but a very very
quick uh primer or refresher about goal
setting uh you've probably heard hey
you're setting a goal make sure it's a
smart goal smart being an acronym
you can dig into the article for more
details you can listen to last episode
for more details smart goals
um
not that smart they've really caught on
in Fitness
um but not for good reasons you know not
because they were developed for fitness
and health not because they have been
robustly empirically tested and
validated in in health and fitness it
was really a corporate tool to keep
people on task and people are like smart
I like the sound of that I think that's
going to work for it for us
um but the problem with smart goals is
that they are
um they're totally isolated you know
they're just kind of floating around
you've got this specific thing that is
kind of like decontextualized it's like
oh I'm gonna go to the gym for 45
minutes three days a week and it's just
kind of existing out in The Ether and
like it's not Tethered to anything uh
and so sometimes people will kind of
make a little list of smart goals three
or four of them at a time there's no
organization in terms of how they all
link together there's no kind of broader
framework for how they're all fitting
together and so you know you you start
falling short on one or the other you
kind of lose interest uh lose motivation
and you kick them by the wayside and
then you start over next January you
know that's a really common thing so
rather than focusing on smart goals
um which empirically just don't seem to
be that great for health and fitness I
think it's much more helpful to focus on
a goal hierarchy which I talked about a
lot previously
um but you want to basically have this
tiered system where you've got a
superordinate goal
which really is tied to your sense of
self it's really reflective of your
values your priorities and kind of your
idealized sense of self and then under
that you have intermediate goals that
support that superordinate goal and then
under those you've got even more
subordinate goals and that's where you
start to see something that resembles a
smart goal you know those subordinate
goals are more specific you kind of
really sketch out how you intend to
implement them in a really defined way
but they are now contextualized within
this broader hierarchy which is anchored
by a superordinate goal
um and there's tremendous value of this
uh for example two really big advantages
I guess three really big advantages
first of all your superordinate goal
because it's that anchor that is really
tied to your sense of self it tends to
be more stable and resilient so like you
might lose interest in this like random
smart goal that you're doing a you know
three days a week 45 minutes but why
though right and eventually you start
missing the third day and you say screw
it I don't care anymore with a
superordinate goal it's hard to throw it
out and say screw it I don't care
anymore I mean this is something that is
fundamentally tied to your sense of self
and your value system so it gives you
that resiliency and that robustness
where even when you run into friction
and challenges and you start having some
slip UPS you say right but like do I
still value what I value and the answer
is typically yes right so that's one
advantage
or if the answer is no that means you're
going through a complete shift in world
view major existential crisis and the
fact that you're like not losing weight
at quite the rate you want to or your
bench press progress has stalled is is
really is really the least of your
concerns but it is it is really powerful
though to to have this framework and
when you start working through it and
you say you know what the more I think
about it the more I think my
superordinate goal has changed
sometimes people or that you just lied
to yourself in the first place yeah or
that it was never the right goal for you
sometimes people toil for years on end
before they actually make that
realization and like one of the happiest
days of their life is when they made
that realization and you start to say oh
all of my goals feel like I'm just like
pulling teeth and pushing a heavy Rock
uphill because this is not where my
heart is
and I should go where my heart is like
so so like yeah like there is that like
existential crisis component but it's
also just like maybe you need to
actually figure out what you value and
start pursuing that which can be a
powerful thing
um but other advantages here first
there's the idea of equifinality which
is the idea that you can have multiple
lower level goals
that all support a single higher level
goal and so um for example if you have a
higher level goal that is to be healthy
for example uh you might say Okay I want
to exercise I want to sleep well I want
to manage stress well I want to clean up
my diet if you start slipping up in one
of those categories you are still able
to pursue other avenues that are
supporting the higher level goal right
so you don't feel like wow I'm a
complete failure you say okay there's
four routes by which I can really make
strides toward that higher level goal
that's really important to me and I'm
still making really big strides in three
of those four facets so while I'm
enjoying the success of the other three
I can revisit and troubleshoot the
issues I'm having with the fourth one so
that's a really powerful thing and then
multi-finality is another Advantage
which is kind of the inverse of that
it's the fact that you can have one
lower level goal that supports multiple
higher level goals and the reason that's
important so like an example in a paper
by Hockley and colleagues that I'll
certainly Link in the show notes
um you know going with those four
intermediate goals you know you know
being be in good shape get enough sleep
avoid stress or manage stress eat a
healthy diet You could argue that
exercise related goals like if you have
a goal of exercise three times a week or
whatever it is you could argue that
exercising is helping you be in good
physical shape it's helping you regulate
your sleep better I know I sleep like
[ __ ] when I stop exercising it can help
you with Stress Management and a lot of
people also notice that they tend to
have an easier job with hunger and
appetite management when they are
exercising regularly not everybody but
some folks
um so when you're trying to get out of
bed at 5am and it's dark out and it's
cold out you need a reason that's going
to be compelling enough today to get you
out of bed right so that you don't hit
the snooze and say screw it I'll get
another other hour of sleep my bed is
warm I like that I'll try again tomorrow
right
and depending on the day the reason that
is compelling enough to get you out of
bed and keep you away from the snooze
button it might change and that's the
power in my opinion of multi-finality is
some days when you're waking up to get
out of bed and go to the gym and you
really don't want to
the desire to be in good physical shape
might be the thing that gets you out of
bed but on different days it might just
be you know what I know I sleep like
[ __ ] if I skip these workouts so for
that reason I'm gonna go ahead and do it
right or I know that I really suck at
managing stress if I'm not exercising
regularly so even though I don't want to
I'm getting out of bed let's get to the
gym right so that's a very short
synopsis of why goal hierarchies are
really powerful
um so that's the first step right so
we've got some great goals in place
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that these hierarchies are really useful
tools for goal setting we've got goals
but now we have to actually cultivate
and maintain motivation specifically
related to those goals right because
like I said when I was defining
motivation motivation is in reference to
a particular goal now
motivation a lot of people kind of view
it as a dichotomous thing right it
motivation exists you either have it or
you don't
one of the main things we're going to
talk about in this segment is
self-determination Theory which is a
theory proposed by Ryan and Desi
and one of the underlying Concepts in
self-determination theory is that
motivation there are many forms of it
and different types of motivation exist
on a spectrum that ranges from low
quality to high quality motivation so
there's really one defining
characteristic that dictates what what
is happening as you're moving up that
that spectrum and going from lower
quality to higher quality and the
question is to what extent are intrinsic
factors really guiding this motivation
so of course the lowest quality form of
motivation is the absence of motivation
which which you would call a motivation
but then you've got lower quality
types of motivation that are very
extrinsic in nature and like some like
if we think of like a super low quality
extrinsic motivator it's like you
literally have to do this or you're
going to get punished deep down you
think it's stupid you don't want to do
it you don't value it if you had any
choice at all you certainly would not do
it but simply to avoid punishment you
will do it right totally extrinsic in
nature very low quality motivation
generally speaking and then you get into
tasks that are not totally intrinsic but
they're getting close right so a good
example is that I read in a paper by
Ryan and Desi is doing your homework
right so you can think of you know a
high school kid doing their homework
right
totally extrinsic would be if I don't do
this my teacher is going to give me a
hard time my parents are going to give
me a hard time I think it's dumb and
stupid I don't value it at all but I'm
just gonna do it so I don't have to deal
with that [ __ ]
but there's also a form of extrinsic
motivation that is kind of moving up
into higher quality which is
do I love doing homework for its own
sake no uh so it's not a purely
intrinsic motivator here where I'm just
doing it because I love it I value it
for its own sake I think this homework
is excellent but you might say okay uh
I'm a junior in high school I want to
make sure I get into the college that I
like I do sincerely believe that if I do
well in this course I'll have better
opportunities for school and that will
set me up for the type of career that
I'm hoping for it's more intrinsic you
are you are invested in some belief that
there is value in this and there is some
part of you that says yeah I'm I'm
better off doing this you know yeah like
you you don't care about the thing
itself that much but you you do care
about what it might be able to do for
you absolutely yeah so so that's why we
don't say you know oh there's just two
kinds extrinsic extrinsic and intrinsic
it's not really so simple there's kind
of a gradient where you start to say
okay there are some more internally
regulated perspectives and processes
that are that are feeding into this type
of motivation as you work your way up
that scale and then of course you know
the highest level of motivation is an
intrinsic motivation where you are doing
this for its own sake and we do see that
a lot in in Fitness I think like
I've there have been times in my life
where it's been
really challenging to take an off day I
love training because I love training
you know so like I would rather be in
the gym than not in the gym like I'm
sure you've had periods of your life
where you're like that as well oh yeah
for sure yeah and so I do think it's
kind of funny I'm gonna be a little
snarky here but like I don't think
people realize when they're in that
level of motivation or it's it's totally
intrinsic and they have just fallen in
love with the active training and then
they'll like put on some like they'll
like do like a motivational tweet and be
like I love this [ __ ] why are you lazy
and it's like well it's not so simple is
it you know yeah it's like they don't
really understand that they have kind of
hit that intrinsic motivation where
they act like they're doing something
like that's really you know like wow
it's so amazing that you get to the gym
every day it's like dude you you love
being there like it's like congrats dude
you found the motivation necessary to do
precisely what it is you want to do yeah
your favorite thing in the world yeah
you were able to do it daily and
congrats on the sacrifice yeah that
that's like going up to a 14 year old
boy and being like hey congrats for
playing video games like I'm I'm sure
that I'm sure that took a lot of mental
effort to get you there exactly yeah so
all of that is to say motivation exists
on a spectrum according to self-demand
self-determination Theory and what we
would like to do is cultivate if we can
uh more intrinsic types of motivation uh
to the extent possible
another misconception in my opinion
about motivation one is that it's just
on or off there is a singular construct
of motivation like I said there's
multiple types and they vary in in
quality another misconception in my
opinion is that we have to manufacture
uh motivation that it's something that
we have to create out of raw materials
through effort and self-determination
Theory by my read of it
um posits a very different perspective
which is that you know humans have kind
of an intrinsic drive toward
curiosity and growth and betterment we
want to do things that we find
interesting and empowering and we want
to grow and master new things and learn
new things
self-determination Theory posits that
that is an intrinsic quality or
characteristic of The Human Condition
however
we are not always at a high state of
intrinsic motivation right so what
self-determination Theory suggests is
that there are times where we are
thwarting or failing to
um
failing to fulfill
our key psychological needs that put us
in a space where we're really able to
kind of tap into that intrinsic
motivation
um
so
one you know a lot of folks will say you
know I don't know like I feel like I
really have to dig deep for that
intrinsic motivation I think um it's
better instead of viewing it as like I
need to manufacture this it's am I
creating the conditions necessary for
intrinsic motivation to manifest now one
thing might be that you're setting goals
that are just completely misaligned with
your interests and in that case it's
going to be very very difficult to to
allow intrinsic motivation to manifest
in that context but but like I said I
think a huge misconception is I need to
manufacture this intrinsic motivation I
think a much more compelling argument is
that we need to create the conditions
necessary for intrinsic motivation to
organically manifest and that's going to
be a combination of setting really
effective goals that are truly in line
with our interests and desires but also
fulfilling our key psychological needs
so that they are not thwarted in a way
that suppresses our ability to let that
that motivation manifest those key
psychological needs we've talked about
about them before on the show
they are autonomy competence and
relatedness those are the three
psychological needs that that really
Drive self-determination Theory and the
idea is that when you are able to
fulfill those three psychological needs
uh you are putting yourself in the right
conditions for intrinsic motivation to
be cultivated if you are unable to
fulfill those psychological needs if you
have major shortcomings in one or more
of those areas you might be in a
situation where the intrinsic motivation
could manifest but the conditions simply
are not correct you're not putting
yourself in a position or I don't want
to make that like blamey you are not
currently in a set of circumstances that
is conducive to intrinsic motivation
kind of manifesting organically so I
want to define those terms really quick
uh relatedness two definitions one being
meaningfully connected to others number
two the need to feel close to and
understood by important others people
that are important to you autonomy is
feeling a sense of authentic choice in
what one does or the need to feel
choiceful and volitional as the
originator of one's actions so you
really feel like like you have a lot of
uh power over what you do and why
basically and then competence is just
feeling effective in what one does or
the need to feel capable of achieving
desired outcomes right and so that ties
in really well with some of the goal
setting discussions we've had where you
know when we talk about setting good
goals we talk about the hierarchy but we
also talk about
you know favoring approach goals rather
than avoidance flexible restraint over
rigid restraint process over outcome
Mastery over performance uh and setting
goals that are hard but not too hard
right and so when you start to look at
the advantages of approach goals using
flexible restraint process goals Mastery
goals goals that are hard enough to
excite us but not so hard that they that
we just fail and fail and fail and Crush
our motivation you can see how some of
those concepts are really compatible
um with with fulfilling the sense of
autonomy competence
um and relatedness not so much but you
you certainly can create goals that that
um that uh
lean on relatedness or kind of invited
into your approach right if you set
specific goals that involve working with
others who are important to you whether
it's in a team setting working with a
coach whatever the case may be uh
tapping into a particular social
Community uh you you can see how some of
these Concepts start to tie together
um so
the general idea here just to kind of
recap short overview we want to set a
really good goal hierarchy leaning on
some of those goal setting Concepts
we've discussed already we want to
cultivate really high quality motivation
which ideally is going to be intrinsic
motivation the way that we cultivate
that based on self-determination Theory
it's not like we have to fabricate it
out of nothing we don't have to do
alchemy and kind of like manufacture
this miraculously you don't have to
subscribe to every fitness motivation
Instagram account and uh
yeah just be bombarded with with a wall
of posts of a very young attractive
people being like why why don't you look
like this if you wanted it bad enough
you would boom you're motivated now
which I as I understand it that's that's
generally not how motivation comes about
but just just based on the the online
content ecosystem that that seems to be
the implicit assumption about how to
generate motivation which I don't think
it is
yeah yeah I don't think so uh so instead
of doing that uh uh you know you might
get like a little uh a little dopamine
or adrenaline surge if you go on YouTube
and say motivational lifting video right
or if you follow the folks on Instagram
but probably what you need is to focus
on the Fulfillment of those
psychological needs and so you know
autonomy one example that comes to mind
you know you'll hear about people who
are really struggling to get MO
motivated to do their workouts it's like
okay well what workouts are you doing
and they're like well it's great I did
this 12-week challenge I have it's not
customized at all there are no versions
that I can opt in and out of it's just
12 weeks here is a thing to do go do it
and it's kind of this faceless thing
that just spits out here's your workout
priorities here's your your diet
priorities and so that's obviously not
going to facilitate a high level of
autonomy right you don't really feel
like you have any seat at the table with
decision making so with I I would I
would put a caveat on that like I think
that if it's if it's something that's
like relatively transparent
um and you can look at it ahead of time
and be like Oh yeah this is what my what
my workouts and like what my nutrition
will look like for the duration of this
12-week challenge
um and that that is something that I'm
like excited about and specifically
opting into like you're you're giving up
some of the autonomy for like day-to-day
moment-to-moment decision making
throughout the process but you you were
still like exercising it on the front
end
um so yeah I I don't think that that's
like completely divorced but but if if
it's the sort of thing where just you
know you you saw online like hey I
should do like whatever this thing is
like Whole 30 75 hard like whatever I I
don't know much about it but like people
say it's good so like you know [ __ ] it
I'll give it a shot you get like two
weeks in and hate it it's like hey why
am I not still motivated to do it it's
like well
you know you you didn't actually want to
do any of the stuff like maybe you want
to make some more of the decisions for
yourself but this process has instilled
in you the feeling that if you don't
follow this like perfectly the whole
time
um like it's binary either success or
failure and and that that goes back to
like flexible versus rigid cognitive
restraint um but yeah like I do think
that I I do think that sometimes that
can still kind of meet that that
autonomy need if there was like a
sufficient level of like informed
consent on the front end uh versus just
kind of of diving in blind and hoping
for the best yeah so again like I
strategically structure that sentence of
if you're struggling with motivation and
you're wondering why and you're kind of
locked into that kind of so if it's not
a problem it's not a problem you know
and there are like you said definitely
scenarios where there's a high level of
autonomy because you made a very
thoughtful and intentional decision to
begin a specified program right so I'm
not saying you should never be on a set
program that I don't believe that at all
but
um like you're getting out with the
second example where it's kind of just
like a generic program and you're like
well you know there's a bunch of ads for
this on whatever social media site I
guess I'll try it that's not a
particularly volitional Act of opting
into that specific program it's just
kind of let's see what this is all about
right and so maybe you do that and love
it um that's totally fine but if you are
in it and you notice I just can't get
motivated for this it's very possible
that you need something with a little
more autonomy and autonomy falls on a
spectrum right so there have been um
there have been times where I've worked
with clients who have really really high
needs for autonomy you know for them to
really Thrive and so I have to you know
be mindful of that and so when we're
doing program design between blocks it's
got to be a really you know back and
forth two-way conversation where we're
saying okay plan another training block
let's put our heads together and then
sometimes when the block gets put
together it says okay you know third
accessory movement for this uh for this
workout do you want to go with a or b
you know or other right you know so you
can start to add some level of choice
because autonomy what you'll find is
that
some people if you give them too much
autonomy it's really uh it backfires
because it can be very uh daunting a bit
intimidating so autonomy has to be
scaled to the individual so it's not
that preset programs
thwart autonomy as a as a rule but you
have to really take stock of what am I
currently doing do I feel like I have
the appropriate amount of autonomy for
me because I've also had clients who if
I say had yeah you know third accessory
lift uh you know Pick A or B it's like
you know kind of deer in the headlights
like I I want you to tell me what to do
that's why I got a coach right yeah and
so it's important if you're a coach
listening you have to be able to
accommodate both perspectives but yeah
with autonomy it has to be a totally
individualized thing of where am I at
now what am I doing is it possible that
I need something
where I have uh more decision making
power and more ability to kind of
volitionally really shape the direction
that we're going here uh competence that
that's another one where it's got to be
really individualized right so uh
obviously it's so easy to think of
examples for this but with competence we
have to hit that sweet spot if you take
someone who's a super Advanced lifter
you know they're saying hey I you know I
I took second at Nationals last year I
really want to take home the win this
year if you give them just like a super
basic generic program they're obviously
not going to be happy about that that's
going to crush their motivation they're
gonna be like why am I this is like not
an appropriate thing for someone at my
level of development right uh conversely
if you have someone who's like hey I'm
trying out this Fitness stuff I just got
a new gym membership it looks like they
have the things I need and you give them
the plan that should be for someone
who's making a run at Nationals like
that's a horrible plan you know like
like there's a mismatch between what
they're ready for and and what they're
what they're getting right so with
competence you have to really make sure
that as you're selecting uh goals or
programs to facilitate those goals you
have to figure out like where am I at
and how do I select things that are
appropriate so that I feel really good
about my competence level you know it's
something that really is Advanced enough
for someone who with my level of
experience you know you don't want to be
doing something way too basic for
yourself but you also don't want to just
throw yourself in the deep end and feel
totally overwhelmed and like I bit off
so much more than I could chew here
right
um again either either side of that
you're gonna you're gonna be really
thwarting that that need for having you
know that that sweet spot where what
you're doing is matching you know what
you're ready for and you feel a high
level of competence if you're doing
something too basic or something too
advanced it's gonna threaten uh that
that kind of perception of competence uh
and then relatedness uh there are many
many different ways that you can try to
you know there might be someone who like
for me I've never trained with a partner
it's never been something that's
interested me works for me very well to
be my own coach and train alone that's
how I've done it forever uh that's just
how I work and that's fine but you will
find some folks who take that approach
and at a certain point they say
I just feel like totally alienated and
isolated I feel like what I'm doing
I thought it would feel more meaningful
but I don't have anyone to like discuss
it with or share it with like I'm I'm
just I feel like I'm on an island here
yeah and and that can be really uh
detrimental for cultivating intrinsic
motivation and so sometimes it can be as
simple as
you know I've been doing my own thing
for a while I think I want to work with
a coach who has some some skin in the
game uh or I think I want to get a
training partner someone that we can
kind of go back and forth and push each
other or I want to join some kind of
online community where we can talk about
our training our nutrition
um you know there's so many different
you could join a an actual club that
exercises together or or a recreational
sport team so many different ways that
you can try to fulfill that need for
relatedness but at the end of the day
what we're getting at here is you know
go ahead so some something that reminded
me of is maybe
oh it was it was pre-pandemic but not
too far pre-pandemic so uh you know that
that kind of changed how how a lot of
people interacted with gems but but
prior to that like like before before
kovid kicked off
um just like group exercise classes were
having a huge moment in the sun in the
fitness industry like there there were
whole gyms popping up where it's just
like yeah we're doing the group exercise
thing like small groups
um thing things like Body Pump and Zumba
in you know places like Lifetime Fitness
the YMCA like those those were blowing
up getting super popular
um and I remember stumbling into a to a
discussion that people are having in a
in a Facebook group for like sciencey
personal trainer type folks
um and and they were just they were just
going in on Zumba and they're like man
like how how the [ __ ] can anyone do
Zumba because like dude you're you would
burn way more calories in in the period
of time if you just hopped on the
treadmill or went for a run
um you know there there's a bit of a
calisthenic component but that's not
going to build much muscle or strength
this is like super ineffective all of
these people who do Zumba are gonna stop
within like a month or two once they
once they uh fail to see the results
they're looking for like this is so
stupid and bad and I I can't understand
how anyone does this in the first place
or would certainly keep doing it
but yeah like it goes back to
relatedness I mean dude
how many how many adults have like a a
robust network of friends uh like
especially outside of the workplace and
like immediate family like I think I
think a lot of people just feel like
kind of lonely and if you ever stick
your head in a Zumba class I mean
people are having fun like there's
there's upbeat music you're you're doing
a bit of dancing with with people of a
of a similar demographic cohort and then
like before and after the class you just
like meet people and talk to them and so
like Zumba is certainly not my jam like
I've done a Zumba class [ __ ] hated it
never went back uh that is that is not a
type of exercise that appeals to me at
all but like the the the idea to me of
just like expressing
bewilderment of of why someone would
like that and what they would get out of
it it's like yeah you're doing it in a
in a big room of of happy people and
then like you have conversations with
with people before and after make
friends and say like hey uh this was a
good Zumba class on Wednesday I'll see
you on Friday like that that feels great
to a lot of people
um so so yeah it's not a that shouldn't
be a surprise but yeah like you
mentioned the the level of of related
goodness that people need in general and
certainly for exercise goals varies a
lot person to person I I'm not the the
large exercise group uh type of person
but
um unlike you like I I need to have
either a training partner a small crew
or just like be going to a gym where I
just know everyone and can strike up
conversations between sets
um the the only times in my training
career that I that I haven't been able
to like reliably find the motivation to
train consistently
um were the times when I was just like
completely trying to go it alone either
either like going to a gym at a time
when Lindsay wasn't also training with
me
um and it was like you know a commercial
gym where people are just wearing their
headphones you're it's hard to meet
people hard to have conversations or
um when I tried to just like solely do
like the solo workouts by myself in our
basement
um yeah like I I just I don't know I
would do it for like a week or two and
be like yeah this is fine whatever and
then like most of the time I'm very
excited to go work out but I would find
after after a handful of weeks I was
like ah there's other things I'd rather
be doing like uh maybe I'll skip this
workout and and then just uh just kind
of fall out of the groove and and in
hindsight it was I think just like
purely due to relatedness because I I
had all of the autonomy that I that I
could have wanted
um certainly didn't affect my my sense
of confidence but it's just like yeah I
I don't like doing anything alone like
I'm I'm a pathologically extroverted
person uh and and that extends to to
working out like I I want to have
someone there who like even if we're not
doing the same workout just to just to
chat with just have a conversation with
um but yeah so that that definitely
Falls along a spectrum as well yeah yeah
so um
I was just thinking I I uh was talking
to someone who had just been to a zumba
event and they were they had never
been in that world and they just kind of
stumbled into it and they were like whoa
that that is an awesome Community like
yeah like it was like the the happiest
group of people who were just having a
hell of a time so yeah sometimes we kind
of struggle to like for someone like me
who you know two people in a workout is
one too many for me the idea of doing a
group workout setting I'm just like oh I
would hate that but I mean hey to each
their own so what you want to do here uh
set a great goal hierarchy so now we
know what is the actual you know we talk
about motivational motivation for what
it's the elements on our goal hierarchy
what we want to do is not manufacture
intrinsic motivation but just make the
right condition so that can manifest and
so we can cultivate that that intrinsic
motivation
the way we do that is by taking a look
at these psychological needs do am I
supporting my own autonomy competence
and relatedness if I am those three
factors should all be pointing toward uh
you know the cultivation of some really
high quality motivation and so whenever
I'm talking with somebody
and they say you know I I just can't get
motivated I I really can't I don't know
what it is but I can't usually what I do
is I say let's begin by auditing
self-determination Theory let's just
look at these three psychological needs
and figure out is there any spot where
we have a mismatch where the things
we're doing are not adequately
supporting the right level of autonomy
the right level of competence the right
level of relatedness because I mean like
I said you put me in a group of six
people working out I'm gonna hate it I
want to do it myself you're you know out
on an island you'd much prefer to have
you know a small group of folks who you
you know meet up with right so what you
have to do is audit what you're doing
relative to your goals and figure out is
there some element some psychological
need here that is not being met if
that's the case you need to address it
and figure out okay how are we going to
change our approach to actually fulfill
that psychological need sometimes
these people who are experiencing a
motivation or just really low quality
motivation they do this audit of
self-determination theory of these
psychological needs and they say no I'm
good like check check check we're all
good with all three of those when that's
the case then I take it one step up the
chain and I say let's go through this
goal hierarchy let's figure out if
perhaps we've got a misalignment here
where the goal hierarchy made sense when
we formed it but perhaps we've drifted
away from it and it's no longer really
aligned with what what you value the
things that excite you no longer align
with your priorities when I'm
troubleshooting motivation issues that's
my process I start with with
psychological need fulfillment and then
I work back to the goal hierarchy to see
if we need to make some adjustments now
there may be instances
um well actually let me skip ahead here
um so we've got our goal we are
addressing our psychological needs so
that we are cultivating intrinsic
motivation that's all good uh but in
order to actually achieve goals within
our hierarchy it's not just writing them
down and feeling motivated right we have
to actually go out and do stuff and
usually that is going to involve uh
modification of some behaviors you know
we might be changing some behaviors we
might be dropping some behaviors we
might be adding some brand new behaviors
but we need to have some kind of model
that incorporates how do humans set
themselves up for successful Behavior
change now there are many models that
seek to address that but my favorite is
the com B model of behavior change so
that's an acronym an acronym c-o-m Dash
B
now just a point that I want to make
here when you are developing an acronym
your dream is like okay I want a nice
acronym short and snappy but the dream
is that it forms a word right I mean
that's the best if you can get your
acronym to form a word you're golden
they had it they had it yeah why would
you put the hyphen in there just call it
the comb model
I just don't understand it comb is a
word you could just use it but anyway
it's not relevant to the theory itself
but I was just like man you you had like
a one foot putt just tap it in the hole
you know yeah but nonetheless aside from
the nomenclature it's a very robust very
solid theory of behavior change and the
reason I like it is motivation is really
the Cornerstone it is the central
element
so what's really nice is you know
self-determination Theory the main the
reason that we're fulfilling these
psychological needs aside from Good
Vibes is because they help lead us
toward really high quality motivation
which leads us right into this Combi
model of behavior change where
motivation is the Cornerstone the idea
with this model is that there's a direct
link between motivation and behavior
motivation promotes you know uh the type
of behavior change that you wish to
implement but there are also two other
factors consider capability and
opportunity and those are a little
complicated because capability and
opportunity both directly affect
Behavior but they also affect motivation
so motivation is at the center of this
model it's being impacted by capability
and opportunity and then all three have
a relationship with driving behavior
change so that that's kind of the
general uh overview of the model and so
what's nice about that is
now we have a really nice uh in my
opinion kind of a unified framework
where we can start putting some Concepts
together so we're going to tie it all
together before I do that uh probably a
good idea to actually Define these
things right so motivation we already
defined
um Behavior change I think it's pretty
self-explanatory we want to change some
behaviors that are pertinent to various
elements in our goal hierarchy
capability that refers to having the
skills knowledge psychological capacity
and physical capacity to engage in a
given activity
opportunity refers to all the factors
that lie outside the individual that
make the behavior possible or prompt
that behavior so for example we're
talking about having access to resources
a suitable environment that is conducive
to behavior change social support would
fall under the the realm of
um of opportunity so what we're talking
about here is
you know we've got our goals we've got
our psychological needs being met now we
want to take stock of our our capability
and opportunity are we living in an
environment that is conducive to
changing the behaviors we want to change
do we have the tools that we need do we
have the resources that we need do we
need to move around our schedule do we
have the social support that we need
um so am I literally physically capable
of doing the things in my hierarchy
whether it's physically capable
psychologically capable
um you know are there things that you
know am I setting myself up for things
that I truly have the capacity to to
accomplish right and so what you want to
do kind of this final step as you're
putting together goals or my my approach
to putting together goals for a New Year
this is the last step is are we are we
being mindful of these additional
elements that ultimately are going to
set us up to either succeed or fail when
it comes to actually change changing
behaviors
so I will say you know when it comes to
um capability so there's a lot of
overlap here between capability and
competence but I don't think that
they're quite the same thing you know so
like when I think of core competencies
to do something it's like do you have
the skills and knowledge
and that would fall under uh you know
capability for sure
um but there are some instances where I
think there's a little Divergence
between competence and capability so one
example that comes to mind I've talked
about on the podcast many times before
um you know I uh
I would
um
when training so I've got like a hip
abdomen injury issue thing that I've
been training through it totally messes
with the types of exercises I do for
lower body training not worried about it
not catastrophizing you know there's
going to be a day where it's all good to
go not a big deal but I did run into a
situation where like you know my typical
training program I certainly felt
competent putting together a training
program that would help me meet my goals
but because of some of the injury issues
I was working through I didn't really
feel capable of implementing the program
as it was written right so competence
wasn't the issue but capability kind of
was right and so then what I had to do
was kind of rearrange some things to say
okay well
I can put together a program within my
gym environment that is uh you know more
well aligned with my current physical
capabilities that will keep me you know
away from really high levels of
discomfort you could also look at that
and say well maybe we should uh instead
of rearranging the program
um and staying at the same gym maybe
we'll go more on the opportunity side
and say perhaps you need better
equipment to help you train around what
you're dealing with right so then you
could say well in order to give myself
an opportunity to really succeed with
these Behavior changes I'm going to
switch over to a gym that has more
specialized equipment that really helps
me kind of work around some things right
so when we talk about capability and
opportunity
it's just assessing what do I want to do
what am I trying to do and am I really
setting myself for things that are uh
within my grasp things that are
realistically you know achievable things
that I'm capable of doing and have I
really
um given myself the opportunities to
succeed so like another one that comes
to mind is like you know you might have
enough knowledge about food and
nutrition to say yes I absolutely could
track everything I eat by hand uh and
use that to kind of change some of my
dietary behaviors but it is possible
that doing that by hand is such a pain
in the ass that you just won't do it
like it's just there's just enough
friction there that you're like yeah
like I I have the capability but
um yeah or yeah I have the competencies
required to do this but man this is a
pain in the ass that's where you would
say okay well one way that I can kind of
enhance my opportunity to leverage that
skill set is to use an app that makes
this more convenient I think macro
Factor would be a great option but you
get the idea right the question is are
you surrounding yourself with tools are
you rearranging your day your
environment to just make this easier on
yourself right so what that leads us to
is kind of this unified model where
before we talk about motivation before
we talk about Behavior change we need to
have goals right because what behaviors
are we changing what are we getting
motivated for the goal hierarchy sets
the stage for all of this but then once
the goal hierarchy is set we need to
start out with the first level of kind
of auditing within the framework of
self-determination Theory are we
supporting our psychological needs are
we fulfilling those needs of autonomy
competence and relatedness so that we
can cultivate intrinsic motivation
relative to our goal hierarchy right and
if that's the case that's good we move
on to the next step we start thinking
about Behavior change and that's where
the com B model comes into play and we
say do I really feel like I have all the
capabilities and all the opportunities
necessary to actually change the
behaviors necessary to start doing this
stuff within my goal hierarchy if not
you need to make sure that you're
seeking out whatever kind of support and
resources you need if those support
types of support and resources are not
accessible then that probably need means
that you need to revise the goal
hierarchy so that you can you know if
your goal hierarchy puts you in a
position where you need things you don't
have access to that's not a
well-designed goal hierarchy because
it's not going to be feasible to
actually make that happen right so when
I'm just getting started that's my
process goal hierarchy
self-determination com B model and now
we should be in a situation where we
feel very well equipped
to modify behaviors and to really attack
this goal hierarchy with a really high
level of motivation and enthusiasm
that's exactly where you want to start
now at some point in the goal striving
process very very likely you're going to
run into challenges friction problems
Etc
um and and sometimes it's it's stuff
that you wouldn't expect sometimes it's
just like oh you know what I moved from
one apartment to another and I'm I'm
just off my eating habits have changed a
little bit my you know social habits
have changed a little bit my my getting
to the gym is a little harder or a
little easier than it used to be so
every now and then whether we expect it
or not we're going to run into some
things where we say stuff's a little bit
out of whack here you know things aren't
going as well as they used to be uh and
when that's the case I work backwards
through this higher through this kind of
unified model right so instead of going
go hierarchy to self-determination
Theory to com B I run it in reverse I
start with com B and I say is there some
kind of capability or opportunity
shortfall that I need to act upon here
right and I start there because that's
usually the easiest thing like sometimes
it can be so simple as
um oh what I need to do is rearrange my
schedule a little bit to make these
workouts more feasible like sometimes
capability and opportunity are way
easier to modify than any of the stuff
further down the chain or or something
as simple as like hey I used to have a
job that had a 30 minute commute One
Direction now I have a 30 minute commute
the other direction the gym I used to go
to was right in between where I live in
my old job I could just go there on the
way home from work but now I have to go
to work drive 45 minutes to the gym 15
minutes back home afterwards uh yeah but
that that's that's an opportunity thing
and there might just be a gym 15 minutes
between your your new place of work and
where you live and it's like ah just get
a get a new gym membership switch over
and you know you've solved the problem
yeah yeah but you might notice that
there are just these little sources of
friction that you're like oh there's
like one resource that would cost me
eighteen dollars that would just solve
this problem entirely right like
sometimes you will find those those
situations where it's like well that
that's a lot better than completely
revisiting my entire goal hierarchy
right it's a little bit simpler we're
still on the same track it's just a
little a little Band-Aid that'll
actually do the trick right yeah so I
start out by just evaluating capability
and opportunity are those my issues if
so usually that's a good thing because
we can intervene on those uh generally
pretty easily uh and kind of uh make
some quick some quick changes now if
it's not a capability or opportunity
issue that means we're probably no
longer in the com B model it might be a
motivation issue and if it's a
motivation issue then I run it in
reverse I go straight back to
self-determination Theory and the
psychological needs and I say okay
competence autonomy relatedness is it
possible that we have a shortcoming or a
shortfall in one of these areas I put a
lot of thought into it try to figure it
out if so great you've identified the
issue you act upon it and then you keep
going right sometimes
you go through the com B model
capability opportunity you don't see any
any fixes you say no it doesn't look
like the problems here you go into
self-determination Theory competence
autonomy relatedness I'm not seeing
anything that that really sticks out to
me here when that's the case sometimes
you got to go back to the goal hierarchy
and say is it possible that this thing
has come out of alignment or have my
priorities and values just kind of
drifted entirely away from this thing
where this is still a cohesive goal
hierarchy but it's no longer the right
one for me because I'm over here and the
goal hierarchy is over there right in
terms of just priorities and values and
and what we want to emphasize so
long segment there about uh Behavior
change about motivation and how to
incorporate it with evidence-based goal
setting strategies but I do think it was
an important conversation to have
because like I said to me this kind of
feels like an unofficial part too like
you talk about goal setting but there's
so much more that needs to happen in
order to put that goal hierarchy into
action and I think the key things to
focus on are motivation and behavior
change
unfortunately in the fitness world
there's
the the ratio of
motivation content to useful or
evidence-based motivation content is
is not great
um so yeah I'm certain that as the New
Year's comes up you're going to see a
bunch of stuff it basically just boils
down to hey hey just just do it and and
don't complain have you thought about
wanting it more exactly yeah you gotta
want it more have you tried well then
try harder you know so I I wanted to
give people
um a look at you know like actual
science stuff about like you know
empirically driven theories
um that that that have been you know
studied pretty rigorously about what
actually helps a person cultivate
motivation relative to their goals and
what actually helps people kind of
systematically think through if I'm
trying to change behaviors and they're
not working what might be going on here
you know what might be the issue that
actually needs to be resolved uh so yeah
I hope people find it useful
do you have any uh New Year's
resolutions while we're on the topic oh
geez I don't I don't do New Year's
resolutions I you know I I think I'm
more so evaluate my life
and uh you know what what I want to
change
um
if I yeah if I have any big Grand goals
for myself or whatnot after allergy
season because for me for me
New Year's is the worst time to set up a
new [ __ ] goal because like one
I get really bad seasonal affective
disorder I don't I don't have any
motivation to do anything in January
yeah wake me up in April exactly no
don't don't wake me up in April because
one once once the the position of the
earth shifts enough that I'm getting
enough [ __ ] sunlight on my skin to
start synthesizing vitamin D and
serotonin again and whatnot
that's roughly the time that the same
thing happens to the plants which then
create pollen and I I also just have
tragically bad seasonal allergies just
horrendous and so generally that starts
laying down
mid to late May and so yeah like late
May going into June that's when I'm like
okay like I've got probably a solid like
five months or where I'm gonna be
feeling pretty good
um and so now let's let's evaluate my
life and and see if I want to set any
big goals but yeah New Year's
resolutions absolutely not that's not
that's not my game you're on the uh the
Kevin levrone schedule for goal setting
yeah uh did you ever hear about that I
heard that back in the day he would
often just take six months off yeah to
tour with his band yeah and he's like
I'll pick it up when the Olympia is
about six months out and then he would
just it completely explode and look like
Kevin levrone every time yeah
um
yeah I'm I'm uh do you have any not
really
um I think I'm I'm not a big New Year's
resolution person but but it is a good
time to kind of take stock and say okay
what what do I want to really emphasize
you know in the in the upcoming year
um
I'm I think I'm gonna hit the gym like
really hard
I haven't done that in a while you know
I think I'm gonna hit the gym really
hard and I'm excited to see uh you know
I'm not like in the am I in the worst
shape of my life I don't know I might be
actually now that I think about it but
uh yeah I'm certainly not the best uh so
I would like to get uh you know get back
to a spot where I'm feeling pretty good
about it uh and just performing well and
things like that so I definitely want to
do that uh gonna do more video content
in the upcoming year I'm excited about
that and also
um there's a really nice dog rescue by
my house and I've done all of the
preliminary steps to to volunteer there
uh and so I definitely want to emphasize
getting back into volunteer work this
year I used to volunteer a ton I I I
coached a Special Olympics powerlifting
team for like five or six years
um and then like with kovid the whole
program was just like yeah we're we
can't really do this
um and so that's definitely been missing
like I can kind of tell when I when I
haven't been doing that so I want to get
back into it but I think I'm going to
start
um rather than doing that same exact
volunteer work I think I'm gonna do the
the stuff at the dog shelter and I like
the work that they're doing they save a
lot of uh a lot of pups from you know
the the shelters that euthanize and
things like that so uh really important
work but they need a ton of help they
have a lot of dogs so yeah I think
that'll be fun like I said I've done all
the preliminary steps to make it like to
be allowed to do it
um but I just haven't started yet
because
December is a crazy time yeah travel
coming up and things like that I didn't
want to start and then say okay see you
in like you know six weeks or whatever
so uh yeah I was like I'll get through
Thanksgiving get through the holidays
and then and then pick up with it so
that's it for me but expect an extremely
jacked version of me and about the 13
months hell yeah let's put a time frame
on it
like any good smart goal right all right
so I think that does it for this episode
of The Stronger by science podcast
um as always thank you so much for
joining us for listening and we will be
we will be back in a week with another
episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign